what's up fellow Minecrafters grab your
pickaxe because it's time for all right
by the merch everyone let's get into it
leave your entry in us ready crows why
doesn't it look good
we got the dirt and the wrinkles who
doesn't want to buy this merch I forgot
to wash it and I need to wear it it's a
little wide goddamn it now let's get
into the memes I already know it's gonna
be 99.9% minecraft tips which is the
only reason I'm doing this in Memorial
oh no oh my god in memoriam gherkin 30
hours that's more than I've played
minecraft oh my god holy freaky deaky
Kerrigan is so pretty
that's rhyme and it carries water she
that's incredible god damn this is gonna
be a tough one to beat
thank you hi Roshan e namaste
this was my childhood hey where's your
again Lowell best meme ever I don't get
it I didn't get it I'm a boomer and my
audience are Zoomers I don't get I don't
get it I didn't watch this cartoon what
is this cartoon super nine-year-olds
well these kids just watching Rick and
Morty now Felix we're sorry yeah well
you're a little too late okay my horse
died because of you here's a few real
tips and tricks baby turtles can drop
skip you that's a word
it's cute that's not real I already know
you're lying you're trying to troll me
again which can be turned into a helmet
that lets you breathe underwater are you
telling me that I should kill baby
turtles you're crazy
naming sheep Jeb JEB gives you a special
surprise
a real one oh yeah you expect me to
believe that you think I'm gonna fall
for that maybe any animal dinner boom
yeah what is that gonna do make the
animals eat me
okay I'm not falling for your tricks
play you played the wolf and I now I
don't believe it's real okay diamonds
are found on level Y 1115 okay
that's useful listen I knew that already
all right I'm a Minecraft veteran
remember can we make sure we remember
this guy's I think he's in trouble I
thought it was real for a second
wait there's wanted criminals
what I've been letting through criminals
into glorious I don't get what Vice well
that's German Oh God take it off it is
time to go which I a good boy
wait [ __ ] there you go yeah gah LOI
everyone was so casual you be like oh
it's fine he just like disappears it's a
glitch
Oh a game that has been out for nine
years just has a glitch that everyone is
okay with wait maybe he's just gone
maybe he's just disappeared again maybe
he's not actually dead I created a
machine we should restore X uragan oh
yes the supreme spelling when you throw
melon into the grave oh yay
how is that even possible
goddamn minecraft hacker how do I do
this send me this mod please I need
Jurgen back Jurgen - hmm I don't know
about him that's amazing it's all
minecraft stuff
PewDiePie submission let's see who you
really are our Minecraft there you go
there you have it five stages of grief
stage one denial stage two anger up
sheep step three bargaining maybe he
went through the other side Stage four
depression no I'm not crying shut up
Stage five acceptance things happen we
must move on rest in peace yeah yeah he
didn't have to die that's all I'm gonna
say it could have been prevented we can
do it god damn it oh yeah we hit 97
million Thank You minecraft very cool
just three more million that's all I
asked we can still beat every other
channel we do not deserve gaming week
Puetz is a nice guy and he brought back
gaming League that's right nice guy as I
said many times before
we betrayed his trust and killed Jurgen
yeah you better be crying how do you
think I feel
you feel guilty well I feel hurt I
shouldn't betray feel lost and confused
I don't know who to trust anymore I
thought we had a trust a level of trust
that is broken and we can take a long
time to heal a very very long time to
heat hi guys I'm Nick I'm the guy who
uploads your memes on a Nintendo 3ds hi
Nick how's it going
happy birthday Elon seven days ago
that's great happy birthday last week a
very epic is he playing Minecraft
petition to put rest in peace Jurgen in
the title screen yes this launch
please hack your way into the game notch
New Era Bros squad fam nine year olds
gamer gaming week gaming Mahon goddamn
flight freak off its gaming week finding
Jurgen it's just impossible gaming weed
2.0 because oh well well boys we did it
FS in the chat for the dark agreed sheep
you all get we you all get weed yeah
well you guys told me I need to feed him
because I um I see my despawn so I am
gonna feed him just enough to keep him
alive it's called Swedish torture let's
make pet deep I name the sheep yep with
a name tag so we can see a real easter
egg to make up for making him sleep in
the nether I'm not listening to anything
I'm not a fool not a fool fly freak if
spend ice this playthrough it's a cover
I'm legit have not dared to put Sven out
on any adventures but maybe in an
upcoming adventure I'm legit addicted to
Minecraft everyone like that
I really thought people just like
Minecraft for the meme like haha it's so
funny we like this game that used to be
kind of associated with just screaming
children
I guess that's basically me anyway I bet
it is a legitimately fun game I gotta
say nobody's born cool except of course
that creeper that's a pretty pie from
the zombies I love how specific these
memers aren't getting like that one part
of the video it was epic though come on
everyone keep saying that it was super
rare that those zombies spawn it
happened it happened one more time and I
wasn't even recording
people thought I legit hacked the game
they're like is he using codes I'm like
me think I know how to do that
everyone on this subreddit giving
PewDiePie tips tricks for his survival
game me you seen his fix on my survival
game there you go it's this gamers
helping gamers it's gaming week we all
support each other we all lift each
other rock
we all make sure we work together it's
the most finest community there is no
one is nicer than a game goddamn block
petition to add you're against it uber
simulator this let me call out their
minds right now nobody Jurgen stay here
yeah and it's the correct spelling of
Jurgen very good do I look like someone
who needs papers that's what I'm the
dumbest person boots I have taken Jurgen
hostage I will release him if you make a
Minecraft weekly series hearing is dead
alright that's a fake Jurgen your
threats means nothing to me it's
official so it's the right one Jurgen
Jurgen Jurgen Jurgen Jurgen there you go
it is Felix every time he passes water
she mother she this is so sad anything
crap bad things happen Tim I hate the
water sheep so stupid this is a stupid
face do you trust the boys yes what did
it cost yet again it really hurts when
you realize that you're gonna would have
lived if I didn't sleep in the nether
this would never have happened
trolling Felix Jurgen dying Manuel army
I hope you're all very proud of yourself
for what you did and I hope it was worth
it unless the friend got dammit I made
some improvements to the house he got
this new carpet should we tell him you
can craft carpet what let Felix know he
can add banners to she'd what that is
awesome
I want that okay Peter buy it I'll sell
Lawai birch but only if you let me host
an episode of the why on your channel
slowly fare well he did say it's only
fair so I have no argument against it
what do you get for me the Minecraft
series I'll take over we did it we
time-traveled but - what year let me ask
that guy over there
who is PD PI a minecraft no no no it's
still ironic we're still ironically
enjoying it okay it's different it's
different ghost on murder spree because
of his dog goes on murder spree because
his horse hears he might annex men dice
it's not gonna be pretty
the whole universe will burn everyone
after trolling pewds minecraft tip I
made this buck with my tears
notice this sheep in the latest episode
oh my god how did he escape I will find
him 2017 49 beats pub Jean popularity
2018 apex fails to beat for 9 popularity
2019 fine I'll do it massive it's
happening boys we're bringing it back
huge fighting skills in Minecraft part 1
K roots fighting skills in Minecraft
part 8 dude that raid was freaking lit
though seriously yes Felix icebergs are
in fact made of ice what is this it's
ice Birds what it's made out of ice well
I thought maybe it was like a snow bird
how do I know until I check it I have to
check it this is a Swedish thing you
would you wouldn't possibly understand
ok don't waste my time
Jurgen was like a father to me I loved
him as a son
what a beautiful quote can we appreciate
how happy is Felix when he discovered
minecraft no I'm just ironically
enjoying it it's it's not it's not a
real thing
Peter Pye holding out for waves of raids
all by himself
dude it was eight because I triggered
two of them at the same time it kept
coming I had to fight another one off
camera but I was so tired of filming the
entire subreddit wouldn't feel expelled
it Garriott I don't get it have you guys
been fighting over the spelling or
something it's obvious lazy arrogant
there's no there's no fighting when
Peter pie it buys two buckets of
tropical fish god damn it from you for
no epic reason doesn't do anything with
the fish but you still hit those five
ever else Stoics well he's trapped in my
house so it's fine he won't go anywhere
oh yeah this is one I followed thank you
very much I'll never mind pewds will try
to put normal diamond on Jurgen instead
of horse
no I didn't know I did you're wrong
you're wrong you got played you have to
smash like and buy the merch now mmm
doing the stanky leg doing the stanky
leg got him I can do the sink your legs
because I'm a gamer even if I don't have
legs as long as you're a gamer it
doesn't matter Anders dragon exists
Felix can I put him in the pocket well
has anyone tried it that's the thing
about Minecraft you don't know until you
try
can you put the Enderman in the bucket I
don't know maybe this is the recipe for
a leak you can click to attach it to
your horse and then okay so I got a
bunch of leads but I don't how to make
it so I need slime and the slime is
found in lily pads oh okay I look for
slime this is a slime when you kill a
big one smaller one okay I'll kill slime
I'll kill us I'm out all forelli been
freakish lime they're slimy I'm down for
it sorry Maria ask for any light gold to
continue your Minecraft series alright
ten million likes let's get it gamers
spend water sheep yet again llama guys
both cow gaming petition for Mojang to
add a new item enter dragon in bucket
secret ending everyone's warning me
about this I thought they'd look cool
they're like glowing and it's cool it's
cool I don't think he knows that during
nighttime he's allowed to sleep and not
play Minecraft a week in a row
Felix first episode I recorded early in
the morning I wanted to get into the
gaming come on gamers the only gamers
will understand doing the stanky leg you
understand you like Felix after you save
the village from the raid
you got the hero village make sure you
go back to the village with the stuff
and trade with them because now you have
discount what why do you know what that
means it already expired I have to do
that again I'm doing it again when
PewDiePie logs into Minecraft after not
being on it for ten years as I kept them
are America god damn he's got huge tits
dude chief says seeing feelings actually
try to sleep in the nether then
realizing he was genuinely interested
and curious about it and that he was
just trying to have fun playing the game
we feed bang him to play
and we betrayed his trust making him
lose most of his inventory make him at
least a little sad deep down inside that
because of that he might not be as
excited about my listen I didn't think
it would explode I thought maybe like a
gas or something would appear in my face
and there would be a jump-scare and sure
it was a jump-scare right anything I
would just die instantly
Jesus Christ this subreddit has turned
into a minecraft tutorial and I'm okay
with it
stanky leg Thank You Blake I asked you
guys can tell I needed bigger also Felix
listen I need to know where they are
they're very important okay only gamers
will understand stanky leg Jurgen was
like a father to me I loved him like my
son speech ten thank you and why do you
guys appreciated the wonderful speech
Beauty pie three months ago I cannot
relate I don't have my glasses I don't
like wearing them cuz I look like my
papi even though my papi is very
good-looking I cannot relate to cuz I
never been trolled by the viewers I'm
just too smart for that PewDiePie
alright do you want to keep rubbing it
in keep rubbing it in and see what
happens okay there it is again
I am the I'm definitely done doing doing
this unless I haven't already done it
Thank You skull so far down you see I
feel submissions
marzia enters the room to ask something
caliber room of playing Minecraft I get
it now I get his pain I get his
suffering
maybe his horse died who knows he might
have been in a moment like that and
someone comes in of course you're gonna
go freak out of my room yeah I can just
die Felix also feed water sheep some
wheat oh here we go or he might be spawn
alright I'm not naming him Jeb but I
will feed him just enough to keep him
alive because someone needs to be
responsible for my minecraft suffering
nobody Felix for an entire Minecraft
Year petition for Peter no no stop
swedish engineer creates the first
remote
oh that's beautiful we're making history
in Minecraft gamers and episode 1 of
Minecraft poops meets a tiny [ __ ] in
the field by Episode three it has grown
and become Garrigan thanks for starting
buying you oh this makes me sad
alcohol meth heroin minecraft minecraft'
do I look that bad
damn alright why is everyone obsessed
with minecraft one month later I am
legit addicted to this game mr. beast I
just want to let you know I'm loving the
minecraft letsplay never stopped Thank
You mr. B's mr. B's has blessed this
minecraft letsplay if we're joke oh my
god boots fine stuff which takes me ages
to find village at spawn mineshaft
diamonds ruins temple wandering traded
will be you make me freakin jealous yeah
I don't know how do I know I don't know
it seems like yeah it happens all the
time
we shouldn't have abused Felix trust
they were just jokes it was supposed to
be funny
Jurgen is dead because of ice how are we
supposed to know he died in a wall he's
never coming back never coming back
sure they're here again too sure they
can be Jurgen three but there's only one
make sure you take care of Sven boots
the lower his tail the lower is health
is okay that's good to know
I was wondering thanks gamers neighing
in Japanese Felix you can't give up now
excuse your fighter Jurgen Watership
Sven sea turtle both cows llama guy a
very epic minecraft IRL according to
Felix cactus equals characters carpet
equals carpet toad equals toad alright
that's cool the Sheep that's been
trapped in hitting the water card in
Felix farm for three episodes the organ
and sweat should be added into - bird
simulator this is gamer facts important
tip for Felix right now he has his
melons and pumpkins arranged like this
they want to grow like this they need a
oh ok yeah I'm gonna change my farm
that's cool thanks gamers so
needs an empty block in front of it got
it gamers that getting around 30 minutes
of physics playing Minecraft every other
day realizing there's hours of Felix
playing minecraft we don't get to see
well there is a lot of dead end bad
moments where I'm literally just
building and focused on building ok you
don't need to see everything you're
saying I'm obsessed okay PT pike are the
dolphin oh yeah I caught a dolphin I
remember is it still here there it is oh
my god
other dears in Minecraft I mean dolphins
do some fanart because the Minecraft
series is amazing
thank you very cool very epic very cool
and very nice Felix is too busy playing
Minecraft and probably won't make it
alive for some time so technically we
could turn this effort into whatever we
want oh you don't say it is a Minecraft
subject this means to me the whole
gaming week I'm gonna make a bed so you
can sleep with me marzia like maybe
minecraft is actually Felix home
universe and that's what hey stop
take that back no more quality jokes
quality's amazing app basicly peeves
house right now IKEA no my house is
beautiful
you guys better figure out a way to
protect me or else minecraft is gone it
looks like span both kai probably saved
spends life because ifs went fought in
the raid he probably would have been oh
my god
this is sad no foods just met me and I'm
already his favorite pet favorite I've
been I have been with boots for way
longer than you amateurs where was that
Punk MHS Felix
should sleep in the nether sleeps in
nether dives and loses half of his items
read it I have made a survey yeah I hope
you feel bad you should do a livestream
charity and do something good do
something virtuous to make up for your
damaging deeds
Iren golem exists hello stone am i a
stone to you what is the difference we
need the iron and I don't get it what
would you do if there was a child right
in front of you
well people said that the golden baby
zombie is what killed the guy that did
five years of Minecraft hardcore oh
great here's the warning about the raids
awesome thanks guys that's really
helpful 9 year olds watching kids do the
stanky legs without legs doing the
stanky leg you can sync Lego you want no
matter who you are we don't discriminate
you guys always act like you're better
than me you're a piece of crap
water sheep ad pocalypse is God everyone
like that yeah I don't know what's
happening minecraft is amazing minecraft
is the Saviour the beginning of the
redemption all right that's it for this
week's gaming week Lawai thank you guys
for watching jaws for channel check out
epic mert limited time only and thanks
for all the memes and good times it's
been really fun I've been really funny
fun fun and I see you gamers next gaming
week by gamers what you never play -
purr simulator you know it's fun right
I'm not supposed to give my opinion but
give it a try and then you can tell me
if it's good or not convinced yet ok
I'll cut you a deal
the game is available for free and
that's a great price
[Music]